we actually have some good news for you
today there's so much bad news in
American politics that it's sort of
notable to have some good news and it
relates to something called the national
popular vote interstate compact okay
we've talked for a long time about
popular vote versus electoral vote for
deciding who becomes president of the
United States and as we've talked about
before one of the reasons that an
electoral vote was initially established
in the United States was to try to
prevent candidates from merely focusing
on population centers and to try to
ensure that lower population places are
also visited and lobbied so to speak by
presidential candidates things have
changed significantly with media and the
internet the way that it exists today
the physical presence of presidential
candidates in high or low population
areas has never been less important but
more importantly there is a concern now
that the electoral vote has actually run
counter to the will of the people for
example if we look at recent
presidential elections we look at the
last five in 2016 Donald Trump won
despite losing the popular vote in 2012
President Obama won both the electoral
and popular vote in 2008 President Obama
won the electoral vote and just crushed
the popular vote by about 10 million
votes in 2004 George W Bush won and won
the popular vote but in 2000 Bush won
having lost the popular vote so in two
out of the last five or two put in a
different way in 40% of the last five
presidential elections the
president-elect did not win the popular
vote now you can make the argument that
if there was a national popular vote
instead of an electoral college the
candidates would run their campaigns
differently but that's the case with any
system no matter what system you have
candidates are going to run their
campaign in the way that they think is
going to be most advantageous given the
system that there is now how could we
get rid of the electoral
one way which is really difficult is a
constitutional amendment it's
extraordinarily difficult to make that
happen but there's another possibility
which I've been telling you about which
is called the national popular vote
interstate compact it gets around the
electoral vote without making any
changes to the Constitution each state
decides how they award their electoral
votes and what states can decide is to
award their electoral votes not to the
candidate that wins their state but to
the candidate that wins the national
popular vote constitutional because
states have a lot of power in deciding
how they are going to reward their
electoral votes the problem is an issue
of math you need 270 electoral votes to
win the presidency so until you have
enough states signing on to the npv I
see such that they have 270 electoral
votes it doesn't go into effect because
there would be no point it wouldn't work
currently there are 11 states plus
Washington DC that have signed on to the
npv I see 172 electoral votes in total
that's 98 short of the number required
now these are all blue states so far and
that makes sense why would red states
join the npv I see if they correctly
perceive that it would help Democrats
and hurt Republicans it's likely that
Delaware would sign on at some point
that's only worth three electoral votes
but the big news that I have for you
today is that Colorado is now expected
to join they have nine electoral votes
and that would get us to a hundred and
eighty-one closing the gap to only 89
remaining to get to 270
the reason Colorado is so important is
because it's not a super blue state by
any means the way that most of the other
states that are part of this compact are
it's more of a swing state and the path
forward to pass national popular vote in
states that vote red is getting
Democrats elected as governors and two
state legislatures
because the path forward it probably
includes Delaware like I mentioned that
would get us to a hundred and eighty
four this has already passed the house
in New Mexico still needs to pass the
Senate that would get us to 189 you have
Maine Nevada and Oregon considering
national popular vote bills that would
get us to 206 but you've still got a lot
more and ultimately we've been talking
about the lack of democratic
organization at the state level in many
many states this Pat is another way in
which it could completely change the way
politics is done in the United States of
America even states that vote for
Republicans consistently in presidential
elections are subject to having
Democratic governors or Democrats
controlling state legislatures and if
they do all of a sudden national popular
vote legislation is on the table now do
you think it's possible that red states
will eventually tag along because while
the electoral college has screwed
Democrats in two of the last five
elections it could potentially scoot
through the Republicans to like let's
say a Republican candidate wins the
popular vote but loses the electoral
college that also that that almost
happened in in 2004 with John Kerry and
George W Bush and with the way that
demographics are shifting it's possible
that Democrats are soon going to be
guaranteed New York California and Texas
in every election which would make it
really hard for Republicans who win so
if we give it time I don't know how many
election cycles it'll take maybe three
four or five I think we can get there I
think we get all the states on board
with this compact yeah Texas is an
interesting one because it's one of
those that there's a there's a project
there's an initiative to make Texas blue
project there's new polling out of
Florida that Florida may be becoming
rather than a swing state a reliably
blue state and some of those demographic
changes definitely could change red
state willingness to switch to a popular
vote it's growing it's growing every
year that's the direction the wall we
are quickly coming to is that you're
going to need to start getting some red
states there right now your vote simply
doesn't have a shot of making a
difference in the election in most
states let's make every vote
matter directly by instituting a
national popular vote